what is happening there reject nation
today we're going to check out the
spider-man no way home imax trailer and
other tv spots but first we got a video
sponsor that we have to thank we might
be the first people to have ever told
you about them raid shadow legends and
if you don't know them you will love
them especially if you're a fan of
classic dungeon crawling rpgs and epic
fantasy you know what my fantasy is
covering your entire body and ranch
dressing and taking it to the streets
swap out the ranch for the tears of my
mortal enemies and you're right on track
johnny well you'll have plenty of
adversaries to choose from because raid
has over 600 epic champions and an
insane variety of bosses take malik
cavar guardian of the void key look at
this guy oozing with pestilence and a
mastery of void magic stock up on
shields and healing when going up
against this guy his poison attacks
could end your entire team oh god who
could stand against such a foe just look
at these championships the character
designs alone are absolutely stunning
and with tens of champions from more
than a dozen factions it's impossible to
choose just one and raids always added
new features and they're gearing up for
something big this december if you're as
excited as chris from 3c films is about
discovering what's in store then now is
the perfect time to either hit that link
in the description box or scan the qr
code it's been here new players who hit
the link will receive the epic hero
chanuru 200k that's thousand silver one
xp boost an energy refill which is what
john gives me on the daily and an
ancient shard so you can summon your
champion as soon as you get into that
okay so what are you waiting for come
and challenge us and raid shadow legends
look at this place
and all the possibilities
damn that was really clear
yeah man do i know you
it's december they're a danger to our
universe spider-man's greatest enemies
are they are unleashed
in imax
that's the way to watch it yeah
spider-man no way home experience it in
imax
i need you to capture them before they
destroy the fabric of reality i'm gonna
need some help
you guys ready let's catch some
multiverse men
spider-man your way home what was your
name again dr otto octavius
seriously what's your actual name
where are we going i don't know your
house no okay okay
i really like him
oh peter do i know you we started
getting some visitors from every
universe this is all my fault
wow this was revealing yeah
we're gonna get to this
i'm gonna get to it together
oh man i was really into that i know
what we do is we just download them and
just drop them in the final cut that was
exported yeah
oh [ __ ] okay all right we got some we
got some things to talk about here
there's a couple of things that are
pretty revealing look at this place
and all the possibilities
you know so much of the
the questions just keep coming up
because of electro here
look at this place and all the
possibilities this is a clear shot of
him
in just human form right of max in human
form i mean there were league set photos
of him just wearing this exact outfit
yeah a common theory and one that i
believed was that the whole thing with
the arc reactor in his chest was
possibly something that allowed him to
stay in humanoid form while being able
to use his electro powers but there's
this other theory i've been hearing
going around it might be true this
version of of electro is actually from
this mcu that's why he looks so
different he doesn't look like max from
amazing spider-man 2 with like the crazy
nerdy hair he looks like cool
construction worker guy or something
like that you know but he's also saying
here look at this place and all those
possibilities which leads me to believe
he is plucked from a separate universe
due to that one line perhaps this is the
building they were like robbing and the
one that had like the the feast truck
outside of it where you see like aunt
may pacing through there's like the
feast building maybe or maybe has like
star tech secretly stored there or
something like that look at all the
possibilities yeah i could definitely
see that being i could see there being
some kind of origin to that arc reactor
thing that would be kind of weird if he
just showed up with it you know no yeah
they have to at least steal it at some
point and he's using it but for him to
say look at this place in all its
possibilities then i don't know they're
uncovered they must be uncovering
something whenever they're stealing
stuff yeah i mean the line like that
suggests to me that he might be still
from a different universe i mean and
they could just go with he's from a
different universe entirely and not the
amazing spider one or the mcu either
yeah you know probably a personal
request from jamie foxx himself can i
get a mulligan please yeah here's
there's like a big one here's a huge one
you know peter parker who was spider-man
yes is that him no
[Music]
they're teasing us
they're teasing us so much this is all
so intentional to get us riled up you
know we had that line in the theatrical
trailer of you're not peter parker which
already is a major indicator that
there's multiverse spider-man that the
tobey maguire one still exists and then
to have this banter back and forth
there's even just further a confirmation
right away you're spider-man this is
definitively clear he's saying you know
peter parker yes is that him no
so which one toby it's toby mcguire yeah
yeah that's the one he recognizes
doesn't get any more clearer than that
might as well show them that's right
you've come this far it's less than a
month before the movie drops show them
now i need you to capture them before
they destroy the fabric of reality i'm
gonna need some help
you guys ready let's catch some
multiverse men okay so you know as many
leaks as we've heard what's implied here
is that okay we need you to capture them
before they destroy the fabric of
reality we haven't heard anything about
how specifically mj and ned why like i
need their help is it the trailer doing
a mislead is it saying like we need
those other spider-men to come over here
to help us out because that has to be
before the whole thing with hot potato
with the little cube where presumably
the spider-man villains are being stored
right and he is saying let's let's see
what did he was lying the multiverse oh
let's go get some multiverse men so
would he have like a special weapon to
acquire them i don't know i mean i feels
like i mean doctor strange has suss all
over these trailers so part of me is
like well maybe he would just give the
kids some magical devices each to work
with but at the same time i feel like
that would probably be kind of a bad
idea
they say let's go scooby do this yeah
and you do see that one shot in the
trailer on a black suit spider-man's
chest on the cell phone where i think
you see both ned and mj on there so
they're both the guy in the chair so
somehow they are both helping we just
don't know exactly what it is that their
role is in helping out with this their
role is to try to help until that's not
enough and then we need to get two other
spiders who can really identify with the
situation it's a bit of a ghostbusters
situation where are we going i don't
know your house no kidding
me
i do like this last spot that we got
because this really hones in primarily
as much as we've been getting like this
big ensemble of villains and heroes this
one really just focuses in on mj and
peter
building up the stakes and possibly
losing mj in this movie but she does say
my dad i don't recall ever meeting do
you recall or is this something i'm just
forgetting no
not not with not with michelle jones i
don't think hey maybe there's an easter
egg maybe finn jones is her name yeah
maybe she's got you know classic mj dad
abusive alcoholic domestically violent
dad yeah yeah just throw something
real emotional and personal and some
social commentary in there
about domestic violence music and just
at some point in your fun little
spiderman on the side and don't explore
it that much it's not important to the
name it's got to be you know fun
fun domestic christmas movies right now
but no all these spots were great and
there's still some good little reveals
and questions that arise and pretty much
a confirmation of toby but guys what do
you think about all this leave your
thoughts down below why don't you go
ahead subscribe click that bell flip
that like button hey we'll catch you
guys soon